die situation sieht also die angst ich
riesig sie damals
der bund der reagiert darauf die
epidemie mit einer kampagne die eigenen
schlug inzwischen sind 30 jahre
vergangen das virus ist noch da die
kampagne ebenso aber sie hat sich
verändert aus stop aids wurde live live
klingt sexy ansprechen sollte immer noch
uns alle mich genauso wie sie daheim
direkt provokativ aber immer mit der
botschaft im zentrum die stop aids
kampagne aktuell gestaltet von david
schepers rod kommunikation und bemüht
und um die botschaft auf ein
interessanter auch keine vermittler zu
beginn galt es das präservativ als
einzigen wirksamen schutz gegen eine
ansteckung zu etablieren
stop aids mit dem kreativen o in form
eines kondoms war geboren
die kampagne kam aus basel und setzte
maßstäbe
doch eigentlich schon deutlich sagen um
was äs gehalten habe ich zum beispiel
ohne dings kein bonus das ist einer der
slogans waren im allgemeinen
sprachgebrauch
[Musik]
das sind der ressorts kulturgut das
bundesamt für gesundheit vermied es noch
mehr angst zu schüren
ansteckungsgefahr droht nicht bei
mückenstichen bei vorurteilen hingegen
schon
denn safer sex geht alle etwas an so die
kernbotschaft konservative kreise
störten sich lange daran von anfang an
opponierten sie gegen solcherlei
freizügigkeit und setzten einen aufruf
zur treue durch bald schon hatte aber
der gummi in ring definitiv verdrängt
die kampagne gilt als großer erfolg
heute zwar mit deutlich weniger geld
ausgestattet als damals ist die
prävention noch immer wichtig mit
starken bildern und aussagen die
provozieren
das ist die aktuelle kampagne aus großes
tabu
tabu ist aber sie nimmt lena um das
thema auto zum drohung dass man sein
partner max safer sex und liebt und das
nimmt der fall thema auschwitz oder auch
sehr realistisch aus mehr wüsste und ich
bin dass die durchschnittliche person
sechs bis sechs partner offset wechseln
die jeder fünfte person sind es über 20
also sicher botschaft wo viele
mythologische galt früher der kampf dem
drohenden tod richtet er sich heute
gegen die sorglosigkeit gewisse dinge
kann man eben nie genug wiederholen
delius kam für das wichtigste nicht vor
aids schützen präservative benützen
dieser slogan von 19 7